on the first video game that's coming
out between now and Christmas time in
the first one of them is the sims and
Kevin always been playing it since for
little before this game is for ya fourth
sell retail product to ever be released
how many expansion packs are for the
sims Alex 23 million five hundred twenty
eight thousand seven hundred ninety-two
I bet 23 was actually says the same
number every time which is weird Sims 4
it's a whole new generation of [ __ ]
with people who live in their houses
chem vanora true tell you who have you
made here this I didn't make Mary this
is Mary um sorry this is marv bear this
is my mare bear as I think how we're
supposed to pronounce that I spell bar
yes oh it's like Mary's actually wearing
her pink gloves right now as well it's
basically huh I kind of like the the
Galactic tight yeah like what's going on
I think that's the closest thing to
actual Mary representation that we will
have on the same character mom I am NOT
responsible that I'm not responsible for
this Danny that's just a good it was to
be Danny that's pretty good sexy not
there it's not a bits not a bad danny
has excelled looking having's to go it's
not you know what you got its felt right
sorry that's about right rob i try what
might have been a little bit generous
there but let's say to me rather than to
my god i did create my own Kevin oh
you're Waldo though so well you know I
had to go I kind of like being matchi
sometimes especially with the color red
the color red I don't like the selection
of hats I like the red hat minus one
you're wearing you're wearing a red on
it on your character yeah but this I
don't like this style of hat I need an
old-fashioned baseball cap that's not
one of those wide-brimmed travesties key
distant vision Assassin's Creed tattoo
on his left ah no but there is a tattoo
if you want we can really yeah I don't
have a I did add a tattoo let's see if
we can go in and out so how is this
character gracious of go have a look at
it it's not bad the I'm sort of missed
the customization we used to have with
the with the textures and stuff like
that other colors that's been taken out
which is kind of sad only to be put back
in at a later date for paid DLC
is that is that a thing kept you think
that's gonna happen no maybe yes I
actually think that's it kind of looks
like Peter Brown actually up there so I
can't so yeah but this I want to show
you mine do some swimming because I'm
very I'm very pleased with my walk if I
can if I can remember how to how to get
into that you got this because i really
like there's a lot of buttons happening
there's a lot of months so the party
walk there are different walks that you
can choose I'm I remember to the side
here so we can really see so here's
here's default walking I don't know if
that's too how anyone walks really
here's perky walk ah this is this is
what I've decided to go with because I
think that as I think that says a lot
about me right there sure it was between
that and that's amazing but I really
feel like this captures the spirit now I
was I was thinking maybe we could create
Chris well okay well we're here do you
want to Chris are you down for me yes
let's let's give that a shot let's make
it wait we're so gonna be like this goes
to minute Chris really now I've changed
my mind what yeah because we can we can
do you just can't capture the ineffable
SS we have the genetics option and I'm
kind of thinking that maybe what would
happen if Kevin and Danny had am yes yes
yes that if sorry Danny had a baby [ __ ]
let's let's should we have a son do you
wanna do you want a child or a child
team Logan our child look yet you guys
get a kid yeah look at that but let's go
through some randomization options
before we really get the Sun we think
it's like I don't have a head shape my
head shaved that's that's pretty a
little recessive gene they're low the
short shorts are killing yeah you keep
buying them for him and I'm not into
okay doc come on how adorable is that as
a guy that's a good my don't your winner
then he looks more Irish than I am well
he does have the green shirt and
dungarees also he's got a potato in his
mouth you just don't see it there can we
make an L dirty version and elderly son
they have to be younger than parents it
says I'd already like we universe
they're living it so here's there's team
I don't know I kind of like oh hello no
do a girl that stops I want a doll how
do i go back how do i go back
I don't know how to go back do they go
back cause i press the dice in the in
the yeah once you hope disabled once
you've hired you can never go back
alright well where I'm fine with this
child okay I'm absolutely far just press
X and builders all right no this is a
good child I like this child let's we
have to we have to finish okay it's
gonna make us finish alright we're fine
we're fine right fine get my fun boy in
one suit citrus am in a suit okay so
you've got different like all right
there oh yeah a little kid God Kevin
Denny thing um we're done that's gonna
know do the walk do the walk oh it got
her off we didn't kids don't have walks
it's a yeah I don't think we can do the
walks we can pick aspirations you think
you should be creative mental yeah meant
I know anyway with anger or social whiz
kids he wants to be smart well I'm were
used to motor which means that he's in
he's a rambunctious stamp i'm pretty
sure that our child would be around
about yes camp so stop with the tips
thank you um let's uh let's elect
something else I Bobby hobby geek music
lover have you instilled in him your
higher my mic one of my personal traits
is music lover and geek is also one of
them you should have seen the deep the
Danny I created which we're not using
childish was one of the was one of the
choices I I gave Danny the child like a
geek makes a makes x-wings fly around
all right let's let's get let's get in
here let's get what was the name em all
what are we gonna name him come on guys
decide that your child you're sending
off into the world and uh how did it get
vana word that's [ __ ] I don't it
should be old wire dungus Mary don't
just that's where don't work awful name
yes I'm indirectly offside I like to all
vengeance of Mary that really says a lot
dungus VIN Maillard our child it's an
etch a traditional Irish name Danny it's
a family name Wow our family's gonna
need more than 10 grand a year feel or
dungus the similar to DES simoleons go
really far in Willow Creek you'd be
surprised does Mary have a male voice
mary has a male voice on pink gloves so
she can clean up
after dungus all the time well the two
of us are making more babies I'm all
right science all right yeah build that
house are you an estimate I don't you
know I don't think I think we really
need see what kind of trouble let me see
the network with you okay I want to see
what happens like we're together that's
true really wet you know what though I
did feel like a third wheel I just no
actually I didn't actually set up the
relationship okay like I feel kind of
bad though so we have legitimately dunk
this is a bastard you so yeah okay well
yes and dungus out of wedlock it's like
you and Mary but we know the truth we
know the trail of the truth you know
literally I don't even know if that is
yeah here's Mary Mary's once she's
already watching TV she loves that TV
watching TV thinking about TV are there
for Piazza clarity in this yeah totally
it's one more compartment it's the four
of us tongass is sleeping you all three
sleep there or does Mary sleep on the
pullout bed I think we're gonna find it
very sleeps in the little bed and the
rest of us just all climb into the other
room that's dungus his room Mary you're
on the couch all right let's get to
let's get to know yes you get to know
each other she's living there as your
beard you might as well get to know her
that's a great way to love the I know
I'm loving this already dungus is bored
already look at I want to talk I want to
talk to you I'm talking to Mary let's
talk about your favorite band I want to
go into wrote hey guys you like my bad
you guys like the bad awfully about this
sick band too i heard you like to tell
me but I really I'm really upset with
meri getting in on my game on the
trouble let's see we can get into some
trouble with her like what can i do two
more Joyce mean mischief means you don't
mean to marry teller mock her musical
taste yet Mary what bands do you like
where's the real man those are stupid
band they're stupid bands you're fine is
the worst Shania Twain's a is a crock on
that you said you like nickelback
justin bieber nickel bag I'm not gonna
give her a heartfelt Kevin he was
totally fit you have just taken Danny's
place now and he's sitting at the table
Oh heaven dungus are having some reading
time to Congress let me read you a story
it's cold how me and your dad had you
and science is wrong this is the real
world you live in dungus I know it's
validating what happens is the sperm
mixes together and then a baby appears
science so listen to your teachers
they're all realize that's really gross
if we're exciting either this is what
happens when you're mean to people in
your household you end up doing the
chicken dance by yourself on a couch I'm
gonna yell at her now I'm across the
room we're having such a great family
dog the tooltips oh you acquired the
comedy skill there being such a jokester
all right let's see you know our this
are we homophobes is that what's
happened the three of us that I go oh
how can you be a home for we're together
go sit down with your family at the
table and stop watching TV all right uh
let's like that what uh if this is gonna
work you need to put in the effort we do
what's the mischief choices with the
kids yeah dungus you want to start up
for prosperous root who lie about Cooper
posterous rumor that he has two daddies
but did you see we made with super sperm
one of them was lie about a birthday
party that's awful the kid lies about
know you like to give life to the kid
but a birthday party yeah so I'm tilt
let's see if we can make them cry dungus
is good maybe we can make dungus cry oh
man we're really are you your wreaking
havoc on the emotional dynamic here
cover their origin achievements
forgetting dunga stickers still trying
to upset Harry she's I'm really upset
that she's not more upset all look we've
turn I think we might have might have
gotten your meter is like let's yell at
marys your meter with Mary is pegged on
you know Tongass has really crap music
taste as well we should probably let him
know probably pointed out he'll have a
shower yet Kevin have a shower alright
shot oh meri look at look at Mary's look
at how I'm set Mary is now look at her
she's calling him try he's cranky she is
really calling her childhood she's like
you are gutter trash all right I want to
be mean or some more and then I'll take
a shower yeah it's like real life I'm
using people
go to our chat if you have any
suggestions will in the shower that all
the things we can do please by all means
let us know in the game spot shot or in
the tub Danny took out the trash /
dumped it on his ankles look at that
look to the right slightly Kevin stop
being mean to marry oh wait wait wait
wait wait what happened oh this is Danny
taking out the trash I'm um you guys I
don't uh I put my hands on it and it
fell over I don't know what to do next
really good I eat maybe Danny's the one
while i insult Mary maybe Danny's the
one that needs to take a shower I gotta
go take a shower this garbage is gross
you want to take a thoughtful shower a
steamy shower a brisk shower or just a
normal shower did Mary just poop off of
the American region pooped on the ground
listen you stopped your foot and garbage
appeared underneath your but if that's
not pooping I don't know what is mary is
always dumping off or to the game spot
shower it's like it's like they made a
massive perfect copier and now Danny and
Mary are both gonna marry stop watching
me shower going on again I'm a so Mary
every see what happens if I scare Mary
not because we're getting close to an
abhorrent confrontation ah de feu no oh
she is too she's played gt7 you're gonna
have to do better than the worst oh look
at all these new mean things I can do
you want to scare Mary Mother as al
almost tell her to turn around oh let's
throw a drink yes haha oh man Oh Kevin
is such a crazy cat you are these
hijinks do it again she's a kid is there
anything more injured by room employ her
mother's allama Harvin says the guy who
just had a baby with another dude you
broke her heart your mom's a llama
that's more of an alpaca in the drawing
I don't know Rick sure does have the
same ring though your mother is an
alpaca see no haven't you guys fight
fight fight fight fight fight fight
fight fight I know some Oh Donnie's
coming Danny's here to spread the good
word no please just go hahaha I like you
he's gonna go bible in your and your hey
guys oh my me just put the Bible away I
guess
there's no God in this house don't just
go to your rooms I'm just I'm hoarding
all the books did he's playing librarian
again not I'm not begging for
forgiveness fighter again hardy bar
firefighter I really want a real fight
this you just made a wet like this Wow
oh yeah go here we go oh man get after
it yeah domestic fire he your hands off
my man I'm just looking I'm into it wow
this is where started on wood John is so
good I fight dungus youngistan outside
don't look at the side don't me he's
gonna play in the trash he's gonna play
in the poop I mean dad you're fighting
I'm like trash oh wait they're neighbors
quick you need to go Danny go meet the
neighbors while Mary maybe Danish method
i were to meet the neighbors talk to
strangers dongers just like I told you
rooted are dog [ __ ] yeah go over and
call that late know that I did that with
you all right let's uh let's it doesn't
look like him oh she's coming over she
heard me heard some screams she's coming
right in ah hello neighborhood
neighborhood police know what's going on
everybody's gonna be rude to her this
teaser everyone ever be a good tongue is
to be rude to or to pay them I'm misses
outside playing in the trash we joke
about chicken but wait now you're your
ID interacting with Mary now not yet no
you're right i'm so sorry you're right
okay description everyone call that lady
a [ __ ] she did just run into your house
when she did fight it's not your
business lady I feel like dungus has got
enough light in fridge I'm gonna start
he's a child of Kevin and Danny I
wouldn't call that light Rudy why is why
is there an earthquake in this world I
know it's really weird I think this
construction happening if the camera
starts shaking we might be having an
earthquake if you hear a low Rumble it's
not because Kevin didn't eat lunch it's
because you hate eat lunch new noodle
leg says we should give the
maybe a peek dan you knock on her door
who won the fight met Mary a Kevin oh
you know what I don't really know how
that I read mary did so let's kind of
unclear Kevin's Jimenez sure yellow that
means he probably got beat up a little
bit right cuz green means healthy yellow
means got your yes yeah I've got some I
moonlets I've one of my mood list is I'm
really unhappy because I'm I'm I need to
take a cold shower you go take a shower
in front of your neighbor okay I'll take
a cold shower I gotta cool off yeah
holdeman you were a real hothead van org
all right I think I think we've given
perhaps the most accurate demo of your
first few minutes with the sims 4 excuse
me but I'm gonna throw a drink Oh God
schmick done there's my tattoo oh yeah
there we go yeah totally don't yes let's
really get a good look at Kevin in the
shower here yeah enhance enhance human
hands we have some CSI computer
technology whoever's gonna zoom in and
unpick so late that exactly we can do
that now we have the technology don't
guess all right don't just go play in
the garbage again yeah don't what is
what is filthy street child what what
else can dungus do like I was Eric kids
yet he drowned in a river you can go
fishing that step that's the first step
towards drowning in a river go near the
river so now first thing is to get drunk
okay can we get dunga strong we could
dungus some tig up now or never they can
play and maybe he's gonna dig up some
buried booze that the teens left there
you clean up the trash you guys not a
garbage mile I'm talking about world I
get on the side of the bed next to the
lamp I have you I know I get on the side
of the bed next to the lamp so see
they're talking about a bedroom thing I
select this conversation would go better
if you're wrong ankle-deep in Mary's
pooey hahahaha been neighbors picking up
the poop neighbor that's helpful she
came over to my house we called her
names and then she Oh aren't you just
let us down again what consolidated oh
no she she's like getting your life in
order where's dungus you seriously up a
cap
seriously need like a neighborhood
supervisor don't guess just dug up some
drugs haha you dug up a drug stash and I
was gonna eat them like vitamin C oh we
can play browse kid friendly websites
how come there's not browse not go to
you porn all right I think we've done
enough of the week can we make me walk
somewhere first because I really haven't
seen that walk in action so this is a
meaningful way I think you said it right
this was definitely a good a slice of
what it's like for someone just starting
to play the sims do this weird thing do
this weird thing makes to make everyone
be angry I want middle of a conversation
I want to see oh there goes daddy for a
jog and there we go there's something
that are some Kevin's those hips don't
lie hey Tongass let me show you how to
find bags and met the teenagers dug up
or something i'm gonna go fishing cuz
that's the manly alright that's it
that's it we're done that's it for now
right yeah it's totally you two can make
your happy family with children that
have really unfortunate names yeah
you